a longtime security director for as key
Senate committee is in serious legal
trouble tonight of course by Doug
McElroy has the amazing story of James
wolf even done
good evening Bret the term security
director may not do justice to 57 year
old James Wolf's role at the Senate
Select Committee on Intelligence any
classified documents sent to that
committee was first received by wolf and
entirely maintained by wolf he
maintained he made his first court
appearance today charged with three
counts of lying to investigators he was
released on his personal recognizance
and had to relinquish his passport
president Trump is convinced his Justice
Department has tracked down a major
leaguer it's a very important leaker so
it's very interesting I'm getting
information on it now happened last
night it could be a terrific thing yet
the indictment does not accuse wolf of
leaking classified info instead he's
accused of making false statements to
FBI agents about his relationships with
four journalists one of whom is ali
watkins now with the New York Times
identified in the indictment as reporter
number two the indictment cites an
article written by Watkins previously at
BuzzFeed in which he revealed the top
secret identity of the target of an FBI
investigation quote Woolf denied knowing
about the reporter's sources for the
article FBI agents confronted wolf with
pictures showing wolf together with
reporter number two after being
confronted wolf admitted to the FBI
agents that he had lied to them and that
he had had engaged in a personal
relationship with the reporter number
two since 2014 but maintained that he
had never disclosed to reporter number
two classified information in a joint
statement the Senate Intel committee's
chairman and ranking member said quote
this news is disappointing as the former
staffer and questions served on the
committee for more than three decades
and in the Armed Forces with distinction
the indictment also notes Wolfe
exchanged tens of thousands of
electronic communications with reporter
number two on the encrypted applications
signal in whatsapp the FBI gained access
to that data by seizing reporter Watkins
email and phone records
big big believer in freedom of the press
but I'm also a believer in classified
information has to remain classified the
case now fits to bedrock principles
against each other the government's need
to preserve secrecy against the
reporters First Amendment rights right
Doug thank you